le reste de l'actualité maintenant avec
d'abord une affaire qui fait scandale
dans le nord en cause le maire de la
ville de hautmont joël wilmotte
il avait déjà fait parler de lui pour
des positions anti-immigrés aujourd'hui
ils s'opposent à l'asco lise
scolarisation pardon d'enfants tout ce
qu'il y a plus français leur seul tort
c'est d'avoir un père algérien
benoît gadré gilles balbastre
explication c'est l'école de leur
quartier mais ils ne peuvent y être
scolarisés
après un séjour en algérie où elle a
divorcé de son mari barca est revenu au
pays avec ses trois enfants elle est née
ici à hautmont et comme elle ses trois
enfants sont de nationalité française
j'ai été inscrire mes enfants dans des
écoles publiques et là on me demande une
autorisation du maire et donc j'étais
à la mairie pour faire ses papiers l'anc
en question et ils m'ont été refusés
et quand j'ai été voir le maire pour
savoir pourquoi la première réponse
c'était parce que j'étais une étrangère
que nous en france étaient des étrangers
et qu'ils ne voulaient plus d'étrangers
à hautmont en fait le maire refuse de
délivrer un certificat de résidence donc
d'accès à l'école communale
joël wilmotte s'est déjà distingué pour
sa politique musclée envers les immigrés
il a accepté de nous recevoir mais a
refusé d'évoquer le cas particulier des
enfants de barques ardennes volonté de
la commune largement répété depuis trois
ans et quatre ans c'est de maîtriser le
plan de peuplement de la commune comme
tous les maires le souhaite le faire
puisque nous avons des problèmes sociaux
dans la mesure où d'autres comme et des
déshérités à gérer donc maîtrise du plan
de peuplement ça suppose aussi une
maîtrise des affectations de logements
que ce soit l'habitat social où
l'habitat privé que ce soit aussi une
nouveau de l'inscription des
établissements scolaires mais en
s'opposant à la scolarisation d'assises
en france le maire d'hautmont enfreint
une loi essentielle de la république
la loi dispose une obligation de
scolarité pour tous les enfants qu'ils
soient français ou étrangers de plus de
6 ans opère pour tous les enfants
résidant sur un territoire communal très
clair loi sans doute compliqué à
hautmont comme partout en france
à défaut d'être accueillis à l'école
publique
les trois enfants de barca sont
provisoirement scolarisé dans une école
privée